for the giants we'll be the big
right-hander kevin gausman six 290
pounder 29 years of age he's in his
seventh year at the big league level
this is what he did in his opening
assignment in los angeles that was in
relief
this should be playable for belt who
loves pop-ups
and the baby giraffe puts it away to end
the inning
on the hill tonight for the san diego
padres will be the right-hander d nelson
lumet
230 pounder out of the dominican
republic driven to wright
oliveira's on the move oliveira's
looking up it's off of archway number
one and solano's got a double
france takes third base or productive
out to the right side one down in the
dirt gets away fred's gonna try and
score he comes and he will get in and
the padres take a one-nothing lead
ball bounces away from heinemann kicks
to the first base side and france breaks
right away and gets in
and the padres strike first on top one
to nothing
machado and fam first pitch to trent is
hammered in the air deep to right field
going back his duggar spinning around
leaping he can't make the catch it's up
against the wall on one hop rounding
second heading for third is grisham he
will get there without a throw and a
lead-off triple for the padres here in
the fourth
and a check swing dribbler by the mound
and it is picked by the picture
first he's gonna be not in time
and
grisham remains at third base
so he was headed the ball was headed in
that direction he couldn't really go
anywhere as it turned out grisham has to
remain at third machado reaches on the
base hit at first
there's tommy pham
this one is quickly through the right
side into right field to base it grisham
will score on the padres take a
two-nothing lead
tommy fam with an rbi single as to the
san diego league
two-nothing san diego and here's
jerickson profile
and profile rips this into right center
field
machado is going to come around and
score the third padres run of the night
as fam
takes third base on an rbi single for
turks and profar the padres take a
three-nothing lead
this is lined sharply by tatis in the
left field hot shot his first hit of the
night
and quickly getting back to the bag at
first
little line drive in the left field
fam's gonna play it on a hop
so solano picks up his second hit and
now the giants for the third inning
of runners at first and second
[Applause]
wow there's ball four two belt second
walk to the end fourth of the outing and
the bases are now loaded so here's
longoria longoria jolts this one out
towards right center diving to make the
catches grisham
gets up and throws it and zustrepski
tags up he will score throw to first is
wild giants are on the board but a great
catch out at center field by grisham for
out number two but it's three to one now
padres
that saved bases clearing for the giants
as grisham lays out
there's
[Applause]
single to right stolen a base driven in
a run
first in a padres uniform
it's this one of the year to left field
back goes dickerson at the wall that
ball's gone jerks are profile it's his
first home run in a padres uniform
and the padres jump on top five to one
[Applause]
jericho profile came into tonight's game
one for his first 15. he's two for three
now and has his first padres home run
rough walk here in the seventh and trent
grisham coming up
on the ground and a fair ball down the
right field line tatis coming around to
score heading to second base is grisham
with his second hit of the night an rbi
double and the padres take a 6-1 lead
so they keep adding on
on the run here in the seventh inning
and a shot up the middle for a base hit
it looks like tatis didn't see it
and the giants have runners at first and
second with nobody out
on the ground past third base down the
left field line yustrenski's gonna score
fan kicks it around dickerson's going to
stop at third and solano's got another
hit
his second double of the night
hit high
into right center field
catch will be made the throw will go to
third
dickerson will score at six to three
slater on the ground towards the hole in
a base hit
and this is going to score another run
for the giants
and it's now 6-4
[Applause]
nice and bad the o2 count pomeranz going
to that curveball once too often
stay hot
slater
two and one to yastrimsky see if he gets
something to hit here he drives one out
into right center field it's going to
hang up can anybody get there nobody
will
it's going to be a triple for yostremski
to
giants are trying to tie this game up
here in the 8th inning
and they will
hit out into right center field
it's going to be oliveris and this game
is tied
the giants have done it again
they've tied it on back-to-back knights
at six to six
grisham at second
chateau at first nobody out in the 10th
there's tommy pham
on the ground and by the dive the second
baseman solano
coming around from second bases grisham
the throw is off the mark
and the padres take the lead 7-6 here in
the 10th here is a liner into right
field and a base hit
machado will score here comes tommy pham
he is in two more runs for the padres
san diego on top now 9-6 greg garcia
with a pitch hit
two runs single to right field
and a base it up the middle
and that'll knock in france
so to tease with his second hit
2-2 pitch
that's a swing and a miss in the padres
win
it's a big night for trent grisham and
the padres as it turns out they win in
10.